So, I'm trying to make over 33K in the
next 33 days trading just 60 minutes a
day. I've already done this challenge
once, and quite frankly, it didn't go so
well. And if it goes that bad again, I'm
going to blow up my account, which is my
own money. Now, my strategy is looking
for a quick flush and reversal in the
first 30 minutes of the stock market
open. All I look for is that specific
setup every single day. And if it
doesn't happen, I just move on to the
next day. So, let's start this challenge
and jump into trade number one.
I think I'm going to get short in here.
>> It's a nice little spike higher.
Definitely the initial target would be
somewhere down here.
>> I want to give it time though, just cuz
I like this spot as a bigger picture if
we're going to move down for the day.
But also like I'm not going to just let
it just do its thing [music] and you
know bounce here and then just come back
and if it's just going to be choppy. I
want to be in this if it's going to rip
down. But if it's just going to do a
little bounce and then pull up then I
want to be out.
Doesn't look good right now, but also it
does look, you know, on a choppy day
like today, it could just be a pullback
and then a continue lower.
Well, bummer out on this trade, but I I
mean, I think it was a good entry. I'm
happy with it. I think just the bigger
trend was too strong to reverse.
So, I'm jumping along here. We've had a
really nice flush lower in the opening
15 minutes. And big picture, we've had a
big sell-off overnight. And so I think
uh we might have a essentially a fake
lower here and then a rip higher
potential. This was a little too
aggressive to get in on this candlestick
because it could just pop up here,
recover this a little bit and then
continue lower. But seeing it pull back
here, um essentially make a higher low
and then I got in on the break of this
swing high here. So that essentially
confirms it's making a higher low and
starting to make higher highs as well.
you know, pretty much the opening price
is here and so I don't think I'll go
break even until it kind of comes up
here to 2x. Big picture here is, you
know, we've been in a strong uptrend and
we had FOMC yesterday, lots of
volatility,
good potential to rip back up today. Um,
I don't know if I'll be able to hold
through that whole move, which is
totally fine. Um, I would rather just
capture the initial easy spike this
morning, but I do want to try and be be
patient with this because sometimes
these flushes in the morning, it could
pop up here, pull back, and then rip
higher. And because today has such a
high volatility chance, I want to give
it some wiggle room.
I'm not going to get out on a 3x here. I
think maybe a four if it just spikes
like that.
Now, if you're new to futures or haven't
landed on a trading platform you like, I
use Ninja Trader. I've used it for over
5 years. You can check it out via this
QR code or the link in the description
below. as this goes kind of parabolic
here. I like to get out if it breaks
that because it's hard because there is
big potential today and a big picture to
continue higher. But there's also
these
I just want to mark these as minor
reversal zones which can cause
a move that's this aggressive to turn
around. That's kind of what I'm seeing
here today. I think at this point
because I've hit 2x, I'm going to go
break even. If it pulls all the way back
here, I'm going to get out. I don't want
to risk a loss at that point.
I I'm pretty much having a mental stop
at this point cuz this is just going
crazy. And obviously, I've been super
patient the whole week. And this is, you
know, my heart rate is spiking and I'm
nervous and excited. In terms of
management, I mean, obviously I'm going
to get out if it comes all the way down
here. I would like to get out somewhere
up here. Obviously, if it's going to
stop, but I also want to see it pull
back here and push higher a bit more.
Of course, obviously, it was so close to
getting my limit there, which sucks, but
getting out right here is still a sick
win. It's still 3x. Really?
Yeah, we're out.
So, we could be getting a bounce here on
the ES. We've basically we've broken
this, but we've given back this whole
fair value gap here. So, basically,
we've come to these this area here where
the market found some support. And so,
we've pretty much hit this the 745
timing right here is pretty on the
money. Um, it's made a new low though
and I want So I want to see it I need it
to make a higher low here. I need it to
break the high of this candlestick to
show me some strength. Um, both the ES
and NASDAQ are aligned and how they're
acting. So that's a really good signal
for a trade as well. Um, but I need to
see it break this high right here and
then do a pullback. Essentially, that
will be good signal that's broken this
downtrend, that it's broken this um area
where it clearly has some resistance.
It's it's selling off of there again.
Definite double bottom potential on the
ES on a 5m minute. I want to see it
almost pop up here and test this area.
I want to see it test this area because
this is where it basically reversed and
this is the current swing high.
I don't want to get in on this pullback
right here. It's not enough. NASDAQ made
a new swing high,
but it's really not that much of a swing
high.
[snorts] Like, this isn't enough of a
pullback.
And I think I'm just going to call it.
It's already 812.
It's not worth staying.
Okay, that's enough of a spike higher. I
would go short if it made a new low.
Just waiting with my order below this
low. It's kind of a funky head and
shoulders, but it's showing good
weakness.
And then we have nice target down here.
3x to the open.
[sighs] Good signal. It's all that
matters.
>> I was patient and waited.
>> Big picture for targets. I mean, I think
going for the open is great. Um, just
trying to give back this move. That
would be the ideal thing. I don't if it
gets going, you know, we could get
further down. You know, yesterday kind
of that's exactly what happened. We had
a spike up, sat there for a while, and
then sold off to the open. Uh, and then
clearly continued lower. I don't I I
think that's unlikely that I hold
through that, but always the possibility
is always there. And of course, we could
come down and and tap this as support.
and continue higher if we're going to
stay in an uptrend. So, that's one thing
to be aware of.
That's not a good spike lower. I mean,
that makes me think I'm just going to
get stopped down. It's going to continue
higher. But, I mean, I'm happy with the
trade. I think I waited for a good
signal. If it was going to go, that's
where it was going to go. That was the
good entry. Um, but you know, it's just
fake lower and continue higher or
continue and chop, whatever it does.
That's, you know, you can't control what
the market does after that. All I
controlled was my entry and my entry was
good. That's all that matters.
Okay. So, this morning the market is in
a pretty crazy sell-off recently.
I haven't been able to capture a trade
in the last few days just because it's
it's been really volatile in one
direction. Um this morning
we have a big spike into this support
zone right now and we're coming up to 15
minutes after that market open the kind
of this 945 reversal timing. I like
I think if this reverses here that's
just too good of a signal. I think I'm
just a little nervous over the overall
bearishness of the market. But again
this is this is what I'm looking for.
you know, and so if the signal happens,
I got to go with the signal. I'd like to
not jump in on a [sighs]
need to be gaining on this right here. I
think it could just rip higher
off of this.
[clears throat]
>> Can I jump in long here?
My stop down here.
My sizing is a little big.
Part of me would have liked to wait for
this candlestick to close,
but it just felt like a little high
chance that it it it was it was the
pullback and kind of rip up I was
looking for. Um,
pretty crazy if it just rips back down
here though.
That's pretty gross.
So, I'm basically back to break even.
Uh, which is frustrating. This week
results-wise wasn't great. The first
trade in this week, though, I thought
was really good. The entry, I think, was
kind of perfect. Um, exactly how I want
my strategy. I was patient. Um, it just
[music] didn't play out. And today,
there was a little bit more uh, you
know, the setup wasn't as strong, but I
thought it was still worth a [music]
stab. And so, you know, the results
aren't aren't great yet. I feel like I
need a bit of a win right now to come
back a bit, but at the end of the day,
I'm trading really well. And my main
focus, even [music] though obviously in
trading, results are very important with
sizing up and focusing more on a few
specific things and definitely being
more transparent with this stuff, it's
an adjustment. And [music]
as long as I'm focusing on the process
and focusing on getting better
consistently over time, the results will
come.
We're pretty much at the 10:00 a.m.
reversal time. Um, nice spike trend
spike again and then it tried to keep
going lower and it looks like it's
failing. I want to see it take out this
swing high right here. That confirms to
me that it's starting to make new highs
that are higher. So, that kind of
confirms an uptrend for me. So, that's
confirmed. Now, the last thing I want to
see is a pullback. I want to see it
essentially come down to here, maybe
retest this high,
and then um I'll look to jump in a long
off of that. I'm going to put a an order
up here cuz if it does just reverse that
and break that high, I'm okay getting in
before the candlestick closes. Ideally,
it would close here and then push and
after even if a little pullback because
getting in on kind of a flush higher is
kind of scary sometimes just with how
the market can be.
Looks like we're in long. I would like
to target the open.
This is the part where you just got to
be patient and do nothing.
Just got to let the the market play out.
Even though sometimes I wish I could
just click a fast forward button
because it kind of just sucks waiting
for your fate to be decided.
That's a pretty gross candlestick. If it
doesn't get gobbled up pretty instantly,
that could be a bad sign.
Hopefully get go it gets gobbled up. We
could there could be a uptrend right
here, but that's a pretty big bearish
rip lower.
Just kind of makes it seem like we're
going to make a new low or just make one
more flush call before it reverses.
Uh, I mean, this a double bottom.
I don't know, dude. Like,
I'm just not engaged.
That was a pretty nice double bottom.
I'm going to get short below this candle
actually cuz that's a nice little spike
lower and I don't want to get in on that
spike and then um it going higher. It
broke that basically zone twice though
so I like that.
>> Uh and then I'm going to go for
>> essentially the lows here.
You know, part of me is nervous that
it's going to just continue higher. Like
that's just part of my intuition, but
like I don't other than that nervousness
like it's it's fitting my strategy and
so I'm just going to stick [music] to
it.
Looks like it's not going to go. It's
kind of bummer. Flush lower like that.
Doesn't feel great with these signals.
Just not working out very well recently.
>> [sighs]
>> So, honestly, I'm pretty just
frustrated at trading right now. I feel
like the last
two weeks I've been taking mostly pretty
solid looking setups. They felt great in
terms of head and shoulders at my
timings, you know, following my strategy
and things just aren't working out. You
know, I don't have to have them work out
very often. You know, I'm really pretty
much break even. I'm one win away from
break even and being positive. So, like
in terms of results, I'm really not down
that much money. And in terms of
improvement based on the last month,
like I'm definitely doing way better,
but it still is frustrating um dealing
with the market just being it's just
been crappy to trade with these last
couple weeks. um it'll have a big move
in the morning and then it'll either
continue in that direction and I'll
avoid taking [music] a trade or it'll
start to slow down and look like it
could reverse and I'll jump in and
instead it'll just start to chop and
I'll get knocked out. It's just really
frustrating I think to improve going
forwards. Uh trying to reset so I'm not
frustrated going into this last week.
Uh, but also I think being a little more
picky with my zones that I'm trading off
of. I think some of the zones are not
quite as strong as they could be. You
know, trying to just pick uh, you know,
some overnight random swings and seeing
a flush into that. And, you know, it
could, but it's just not as high of a a
riskreward or higher probability.
I'm going to close out here. here. I
mean, the market opened up here and just
went parabolic and broke through every
level I was looking at. We have this
massive uptrend that it's holding. Um,
even if it breaks at, it's likely to
just pull back and continue higher or
pull back and chop around. Um,
you know, another day of being patient.
Just got to stick to my strategy.
This week has just been so choppy. you
haven't taken a trade this whole week.
It's just been so back and forth. Every
single day seems like it's been [music]
just choppy at the open for the first 30
40 minutes and then it kind of moves.
We've been having huge moves in the
market, but they haven't been happening
in you know my window of trading. And so
that's been really frustrating overall
for the month. I think I'm down like 3K
which is basically like -2R. So, I would
say basically break even for the month,
which isn't great, but comparing it to
the last month, it's a massive
improvement. And when it comes to
trading, it's all about the big
improvement over the long term. Not
every month is going to go great, even
if I'm trading perfectly. And as well as
I am honestly, frankly, really drained.
I'm going to take all of December off
from trading. I'm going to go climb some
mountains in Ecuador and training for
that has been really draining, too. And
so hopefully come back the new year with
a lot more energy and focus on trading
so I can finally start to make some
money at this new size and grow my
account next year versus, you know,
dealing with a massive adjustment and
then starting to get it. And so, you
know, again, at the end of the day,
trading is all about just consistent
growth over time.